welcome ladies and gentlemen to uh
another youtube special uh and another
grandmaster plays a beginner video so a
couple of months ago on
on a whim i decided to record a a video
where i basically played a longer chess
game a 15-minute chess game against
a player in in the rough sort of
beginner range uh
and i sort of in great detail explained
all of my moves
uh and again i did it on a whim but it
really has taken off and then the
feedback
has been uh amazing and i really
appreciate that and as a response i
i decided to make another one of these
videos where i basically play a player
in the beginner slash intermediate
rating range
on chess.com and i will walk through
all of my moves and all of my thinking
processes and hopefully if i win the
game
i'll talk about exactly the elements
required
and the elements that led me to ultimate
victory so without further ado
i'm going to seek a game on chess.com a
rapid game
and we're going to wait for we're going
to wait for an opponent that sometimes
takes
uh quite a while uh and in the meantime
just wanted to sort of outline very
quickly the rationale behind
well i won't outline anything because
the game is underway and i have the
white pieces
and i like to customarily start with the
movie four
[Music]
okay so here we see something called the
modern defense which
uh to a lot of you i'm sure is is
probably unfamiliar black plays the move
g6 now
this is rather uncommon normally black
plays e5 or he plays the sicilian with
c5 now
the immediate drawback of the move g6
right
is that black does not occupy the center
and black does not make even a claim at
the center
so i will take this opportunity to
occupy the center with my own pawns
now am i implying that the move g6 is
bad no it's actually not in fact
i often play this move myself with the
black pieces what black is doing
is called fianchettoing the bishop
that's an italian term
which simply means bringing the bishop
to the longest diagonal on the
chessboard you can fianchetto
on the other side of the board as well
the drawback of this of course is that
as i said black doesn't occupy the
center he lets me occupy the center with
my
pawns and now i'm gonna bring out my
pieces uh in order to
keep these pawns nicely protected so
what is the point of
of this fiance what is the point of the
modern if black plays this correctly
then he's gonna use essentially his
pieces to try to apply pressure on my
on my center this is a hyper modern
opening
on hyper modern openings were sort of
developed in the 1920s as part of a
shift in chess thinking
uh where people started realizing that
controlling the center with pawns while
important
isn't the only thing that matters and a
lot of openings
uh can survive the test of time uh by
giving your opponent control of the
center which would have been unthinkable
uh years ago you know let's say 150
years ago
so you give your opponent control of the
center and then you attack that center
from a distance with some of your pieces
so the way that i want to develop my
pieces here
is with an eye toward protecting uh the
central pawns in particular
let's take a look at this bishop on c1
where should i put it well i'm going to
put it on e3
because i want to give some
reinforcement to this pawn on d4 so that
if he brings his knight out to c6
he's not going to be attacking it okay
so he goes c6
uh and in general i'm a big proponent of
always asking what your opponent wants
that's a question which sort of has to
circulate in your minds
basically all of the time i mean anytime
you're in an unfamiliar position and
this move c6 what could the intention be
well first of all maybe he wants to
bring his queen out but it's pretty
early
that's not a dangerous idea what is more
annoying is
queen side expansion with b5 i don't
want to let him occupy space on the
queen side and potentially bring his
pawn to b4
so how can i prevent this well to the
rescue comes my corner pawn i'm going to
push it up to a4
and now the move b5 would end up
blundering upon i would simply take it
with my pawn
he would take it with his and i would
take it either with my bishop
or with my knight so he ends up
developing his knight now
i'm going to make a very important move
now those of you who are familiar with
this type of position
i generally know that white tries to
castle queenside
in such a position and attack black's
king if black castles kingside this is
called
opposite side castling and it's a
situation in which both sides try to
attack
the opposing king on their side of the
board
and if we anticipate the black is going
to castle
what are going to be the elements of the
attack and i'll talk about this a little
bit later i mean hopefully he does
castle but
let's first take care of the immediate
business and that is that this knight
has
the annoying possibility of jumping to
g4 and dislodging my bishop from
e3 so i don't want that to happen but i
can prevent it with h3
but i want to prevent it in a way that
also gives a little bit more
reinforcement to my center so i'm going
to play the move f3
and after the game i will talk a little
bit more about why
i am playing f3 when it seems to be a
violation of
uh some key chess principles right i'm
taking away that square from the knight
uh and in general the move f3 is known
as quite a weakening move
so our opponent has indeed castled and
he continues to play fast
so what are the elements of the attack
against black's king well there's going
to be two things that i want to
bring to everyone's attention the first
is this bishop on g7
eventually this bishop will probably
have to get traded
if i am to reach uh our
you know the black king how is this
bishop going to get traded well there is
one very typical method
that allows us uh to trade that bishop
and that is to put the queen
on d2 which i'm going to do right now
and then to bring the bishop over to h6
why does that force the bishop trade
well because there's nothing black can
do about it if he drops his bishop back
that's going to drop the exchange that's
going to drop the rook not desirable at
all
and otherwise i'm either going to take
the bishop or he's going to take mine
and then the queen is going to take the
place of my bishop and actually serve as
a very important attacker so
this is an important situation for my
opponent to respond accurately
and if i were playing black here i would
try to distract white's attention so my
attention
by striking in the center and as i say
that he does exactly that
so the tempting move for us here would
be bishop h6 but let's
think that through for a second if we go
bishop h6
he takes our bishop we take our his
bishop with our queen
and if you look carefully at this pawn
on d4 which i've just highlighted in
blue
that pawn is lost we lose a central pawn
not desirable
next question we ask ourselves can we
reinforce the pawn on d4 can we maybe
bring a piece out
and maybe take that pawn under further
control to prepare bishop h6
well we absolutely can right we can
develop our knight to e2
now is this the optimal development
square for the night not necessarily
i'm blocking off my bishop i realized
that but chess is all about priorities
right
and uh the expression that i always like
to repeat
is you can't make an omelette without
breaking some eggs and that's very true
in chess i actually hate omelets but
um more about that later but the thing
is our priority here is to attack
black's kit right that is our absolute
top
top on the list and in order to do that
we're going to have to make some
figurative and perhaps even literal
sacrifices
uh such as sub-optimal development for
some of our other pieces now he ends up
taking the pawn
we're gonna take that with our knight uh
which allows us now to centralize our
knight which is a good thing
but our opponent is is actually playing
some sensible moves here
and if i were him i would continue to
operate in the center
by playing d5 continuing to distract my
attention
from basically the plan of training
bishops and
attacking the king side so we'll see
what black does here
now uh the move a4 that i played okay he
does play d5
very interesting now what do we do what
do we do
so the first inclination would be to
take on d5 right but that would not be a
good idea by opening up the center
we expose our king and if we expose our
king then the move f3
uh i'll start regretting that move
because he might plan to rook on ea i
don't want to do that i want to keep the
center closed
what does captioning not
[Music]
now available um my opponent is
certainly playing
very very well in the opening uh but
that's part of what chess
is right sometimes you're going to get
someone who is on a roll who plays some
good moves
and you want to keep being disciplined
you want to keep sticking to
your fundamental ideas and you want to
believe
that that stuff is going to actually
work so
we have a small problem because he's
attacking the pawn on on e5 it that
doesn't seem to be a problem we can
protect it with our pawn
but if we protect it with our pawn then
he pushes his pawn up to c5 attacking
our knight
we have to move the knight away from d4
and then he's going to push the other
pawn to d4 and
if you have a chessboard lying nearby
you can absolutely follow along on that
board
but the upshot of that is that we're
going to lose a piece we're going to
lose a minor piece to a fork that's not
good
so we need to find another way to defend
this pawn but it turns out if we look
very carefully we don't actually need to
defend it
we can push it we can push it up to e6
because if he takes what happens then we
take with the knight
that is a fork on his queen and his rook
very undesirable for black he's gonna
lose in exchange
so if he knows what he's doing and so
far we have every reason to believe that
he does
he has to move his knight he he
shouldn't take this pawn
he has to make us take his pawn on f7
but
let's assume for a second that that
happens what is that going to lead to
it's actually going to be beneficial to
us because we're going to eliminate one
of the key pawns
that form his defensive foundation on
the king side so if we're thinking about
attacking
uh then you know that's gonna be a
pretty uh pretty nice advance
uh that's gonna be a pretty nice benefit
for us that we've eliminated one of the
pawns surrounding his king
so i'll put it this way i think that
black is doing great here
but it's the kind of position which is
very very hard to play
unless you have a lot of experience
there's a lot of pitfalls and landmines
that are very easy to step on if you
haven't played these kinds of positions
before when i say these kinds of
positions what i really mean
are positions with opposite side
castling positions where the sides have
castle to opposite sides and they're
attacking each other's kings
uh there's a lot of tactics that are
that is involved in such a situation
uh and probably many of you are here
after watching queen's gambit
which i thoroughly enjoyed and you know
beth harmon would be
very good at these types of positions
opposite side castling that's
right upper alley and it's actually
right up my alley as well um
because i have a very aggressive style
so i really enjoy these kinds of
positions let's see what he ends up
doing
he's definitely trying to mull all of
these options over
and he's decide should i take on e6 we
can almost see the wheels turning in his
brain
uh and the 15 minute chest is good
because i both sides have the time to
really
think through uh the ramifications of
all the moves unlike bullet chests or
blitz chests which is three minutes per
game uh in 15-minute chess you can
really think
think stuff through and he does he plays
95 another very good move
all right so what do we do we kind of
concluded already that
we need to get rid of this pawn because
it's it's currently being attacked by
two pieces
so let's capture his pawn on f7 he's
probably going to take with a rook would
be my assumption
uh keeping his own knight in the center
and
once he takes with a rook right we have
to pay attention to the fact that the
center has been opened
uh when i say that i mean really the
e-file has been opened and our king is
on the ifa i don't like that
let's talk our king away somewhere where
can we talk our king well as we already
know
we want to castle long now i know some
of you might be looking at this movement
saying whoa
what are you doing didn't you push your
pawn out to a4 now you're castling on
the same side
where you push the pawn out well yes i
realized that that may
look weird uh i know
but um the reality is
again and again and again i always
repeat this you can't make an omelet
without breaking some eggs just because
we have one pawn that's not on its
initial square
does it mean that he's going to
checkmate us in two moves
because for one thing that pawn on a4 is
protected
okay that pawn on a4 is protected it's
not going to be that easy to attack even
if he brings his queen to a5 he's not
threatening to take it
the other thing is that god even if
worse comes to worse
he somehow finds a way to take the pawn
we can slide our king over to b1
and amazingly even if we imagine that
the pawn is gone
it's not like he's gonna have immediate
checkmating ideas either
so this is what i always advocate for if
you're
you know you're getting more experienced
in chess and and you're trying to make
inroads and and become a better player
one thing that often holds players back
are these knee-jerk assumptions that
people make about certain positions you
know you look at a pawn like this and
say i can't castle
long because the pawn is is out on a4
but
you know the more experience you get the
more you want to question those
assumptions you initially make
about certain positions what that allows
you to do is essentially formulate your
own vision of the game and
you know it allows you to know when you
should violate
basic principles and when you should
abide by them and there's a time for
both
okay so our opponent is is burning
through his clock he's now
at 10 minutes and 30 seconds still
plenty of time for both of us
and while he's thinking and there's a
lot to think about here let's talk a
little bit about what my plan
in this position is i've already hinted
at some of the
elements of that plan but now that we
have eliminated his f pawn
uh there's one idea in particular that
is going to be quite a bit stronger than
it would be with the fba on the board
okay but
red alert let's interrupt that because
he's got c5 has attacked the knight
and uh i'm sure that quite a few of you
were wondering what i would do
uh in this scenario because i previously
pointed this out and said that this
would win a piece but the situation has
changed a little bit
a first order of business for us is to
drop the knight back it's being attacked
and we drop it back with tempo we attack
the pawn now with two different pieces
but it may seem that black plays the
aforementioned mood d4 which
i pointed out and he wins a piece right
he he forks the bishop and the knight
and again
this is precisely the kind of situation
where you want to look past
the superficial indicators of the
position now what you want to see
is the fact that when he plays d4 he
isn't actually threatening to take
either of these pieces
because look at the queen on d8 it's
actually being x-rayed by
our queen and by the rook not that that
matters uh so he cannot afford to give
up the queen and so after d4
we are going to have a very important
tempo that we are going to have to use
to somehow get ourselves out of the fork
because if we don't then he's going to
move his queen away and well then he
actually is going to be giving us a fork
okay so i hope this is making sense
i can guarantee you that our opponent is
is mulling over the options here he's
definitely considering d4
but if he doesn't play d4 then we're
going to take that pawn on d5 and when
we do
that d file which opens up is going to
be very problematic for him
because i want you to look at one and
notice one very important thing
in all of the stuff that's happened we
have actually gained a nice lead in
development because i have developed
basically most of my pieces and maybe
other than the bishop but the bishop can
also be playing a tangential role it can
go to c4 at some positions
he on the other hand my opponent is
completely undeveloped on the queen side
three of the pieces
are are on initial squares and it's
going to be very hard to sustain
for a long period of time a position
with an open center
where you haven't developed any of your
pieces on one side of the board
so i'm pretty sure that our opponent is
paying attention to that and then he's
trying to find workarounds he goes
c4 it's actually a very interesting move
so
what he's doing is he's he's attacking
our knight and this time he really is
threatening to capture it we have to
move the knight where do we where do we
move it well there's a couple of
candidate options i don't want to move
it to a1 uh that seems
that's actually not such a bad idea
because it leaves the d5 pawn
very weak but let's put that on the back
burner for now
so what i want to find ideally is a
square
that fulfills or checks two boxes keeps
the knight active
number one and number two it doesn't
obstruct
our attack over the uh d5 pawn so
a move that would be very tempting is
knight to d4 but knight to d4 as good as
it looks
uh relinquishes our attack on the d5 so
are there any other squares
which you know are relatively active and
also allow us to keep the pressure on
this weak pawn on d5
well if you look around the queen side
you might find such a square and that is
the square c5
which where which is where we're going
to put our knight obviously this doesn't
tell the whole story he can chase the
knight away with b6
but if you remember if you remember that
the queen on d8 is pinned or rather the
pawn is pinned
we can actually put this knight on e4
you can put this knight on a square
that is supposedly defended by the pawn
but we already know that this pawn on d5
cannot actually move so it's a mood
point
we can put the knight on e4 centralizing
it and then on the next move we can
eliminate the pawn on d5 eliminating the
danger
to that knight on e4 so i think that
that's probably what's going to happen
my guess is he's going to play b6 maybe
he realizes that
i have this 94 idea in mind and he's
trying to come up with something
different but it's a very interesting
position and this is exactly where we
see
uh the the price that he pays for not
developing his queen side because
had black had all of his you know pieces
developed tonight on c6 bishop on f5
uh then it would have been a lot easier
to deal with the attack that i'm
orchestrating on that d5 pawn as it
stands he doesn't have the resources
necessary
to protect against that and i'm very
curious to see how he's going to deal
with that so
we're going to keep in on what he does
in the meantime uh
before he played c5 i was going to
briefly mention what the king side ideas
are which might be completely moot
because we're going to end up taking the
pawn on d5 and playing in the center
but were we to play on the king side one
way that we can often start an attack is
by opening files
files are like the currency of an attack
without open files for our rooks and our
queen
i was gonna say our queens but i'm
assuming uh you haven't promoted
multiple queens yet
assuming you have only one queen files
are crucial for the rook and the queen
oh now i said the rooks as singular man
i am a complete mess
rooks and queen how hard is it to say
now it is possible
to conduct a complete attack without an
open file
right just with the binder pieces or
maybe with the queen on a particular
square
and then there's ways of doing that but
it's a lot easier when you do have an
open file by the way he goes b6 so we're
going to slide the knight to e4 as
planned uh and we're going to see what
he does
and so in order to open up a file around
black's king
a very typical technique in such
positions is to push this pawn up to h5
and then capture the pawn on g6 thereby
opening up
the file for the rook on h1 now if you
remember i mentioned earlier
that the bishop on g7 should often be
traded off by putting our bishop on h6
so i'm asking you to do a lot of
visualization here which i know is quite
challenging and
again if you have a board lying around
you're welcome to sort of try to
reproduce what i'm saying on a board and
i'll go after this
i'll go over this after the game but if
you can imagine that the bishop on g7 is
gone from the board
and the h file is open where can white
put his queen well white can put it on
h6
where it will combine with a rook on h1
and threaten a bunch of checkmates such
as the one on h8
but our opponent has made a move let's
switch back to
the task at hand okay so he's gone
bishop p6 lending support to the pawn
on d5 can we take that pawn well we can
right we can take he takes takes
takes takes and we're up upon in the end
game
another way of counting this we have one
two three attackers on the pawn he has
one
two defenders and the rook does count as
an attacker i know
this might be confusing to some people
but the rook is an attacker
by x-ray right because the queen is
eventually to move away
and then the rook is going to unfurl
itself and it's going to defend the
queen
but it's very important to look for a
better move rather than just
you know rather than just slamming
knight takes d5 onto the board and there
actually is a better move here so what
i'm seeing is the relationship
between the bishop and the rook the
bishops in the rook are on a forkable
spot
and when we have our knights centralized
like this we should always be looking
for forks by default
because that's what centralized knights
do it controls they control a lot of
squares
and they can produce these kinds of
forks now this fork doesn't actually win
his bishop or his rook he can slide his
rook over and protect his bishop at the
same time
but what this trade is going to do is
it's going to attenuate it's going to
weaken
his control over the d5 square and not
only that but once we take the pawn on
d5 if my bishop ever comes out to c4
there will be hell to pay because he
will no longer have a
light squared bishop to keep my bishop
at bay so i'm making an investment in my
future here
i sound like i'm a retirement planner or
something but sometimes that's how you
want to play chess right
it's almost as if you're planning for
retirement you're planning for stuff
that may happen
later down the line and you don't know
exactly how it's going to happen or even
whether it's going to happen that's what
makes chess such an amazing game
partially uh and and also what makes it
so challenging and at times so very
infuriating is that not only do you have
to monitor everything that's going on
right now
uh in the current position but you also
have to
prognosticate and predict all of these
uh ways that the game can potentially
continue and you have to prepare for
them
and that skill is very very difficult
now what i'm trying to show here is how
i'm preparing for that future
where i'm thinking that eventually my
bishop is going to come out to c4 now
why do i think so
because if you follow the line he's
probably going to do this so you won't
have to visualize for much longer
but after we take the bishop and he
takes and we take well that's not what
we the pawn does not fly
backward we take on d5 if you notice the
knight on e5 it is the only piece then
that guards the pawn on c4
and the knight is very easy to dislodge
we can do that with a move f4
forcing the knight away and then that's
it our bishop can
i cannot draw arrows today our bishop
comes out to c4 and we win the game very
quickly so already
his position is on the verge of collapse
even though it doesn't seem that way it
seems that everything is fine black's
position is
is chugging along but as evidenced by
his time consumption
uh his position is is on the verge of
complete collapse here particularly when
we take the spot on d5
uh i just don't see a way for him to
coordinate his remaining pieces
in time to prevent uh the future assault
so is there anything else that black can
do here well he can
okay so he does go rookie seven we take
his bishop
he's i assume going to take our knight
and we take on d5 with our knight
now very quickly while he's thinking
could we have taken on d5 with our queen
what would have been
the pros and cons of that we could have
we absolutely could have taken with the
queen that would have forced the queen
trade because
if you look at the queen on d5 it's
attacking both rooks so he's got to take
it
and then we can take with the knight and
we have an amazing end game right the
queens have gone off the board so it's
an end game
um and by the way not all positions with
the queen gun are
end games but i would quantify this uh
qualify this as an end game
so that would have been probably maybe
even better
but i like playing with the queens on
the board i feel like it can be a little
bit more instructive for certain players
and the other good thing about this okay
he's got knight t3 check so
again red alert let's unpack this move
this looks imposing
it's actually not intimidating at all
what is he doing let's unpack this move
what he's doing is what i call an
interception tactic there's probably a
better name for it
there's even probably a proper name for
it but you can see that he's
intercepting
my protection of this knight on on d5
he's putting his knight
against the queen and the rook and he's
forcing something to land on d3
and that's something whether it's a
bishop or a pun it's not going to be a
queen i don't want to give away the
queen
that something is going to preclude my
defense of the knight on d5 he's going
to be able to take it with his queen
so in effect it's just a trade right
it's just a trait of pieces
and nothing more than that but the
reality is it doesn't actually help him
because here's what i'm going to do i
don't want to take the night with the
pawn and ruin
the protection of mike i'm going to take
with the bishop and
he can actually take the bishop too
which he does but now we take with the
queen we reinforce
our defense of the night and we win a
second pawn
now the negative of this is that we have
gotten rid of our light squared bishop
and i had very big
aspirations for this bishop if you can
remember i was gonna put it on c4
but that's exactly what i mentioned you
have to be very flexible in chess
there's
anything can happen and you need to be
ready for these eventualities and you
need to embrace them
and so we're two puns up we have
beautiful control of the center we have
a knight on d5 that's just
waiting to you know to go on to greener
pastures there's a lot of tactics that
surround this entire relationship here
uh
and we'll see how how our opponent tries
to handle that
but what tactics am i immediately
thinking of well the first thing i think
of is some sort of a discovered check
the discover check
or discovered attack is when you move a
piece away from a particular square
usually with check and you expose
behind that piece some sort of attack on
a particular piece that's that's being
exposed
those that is probably going to make its
way to
whatever anti-merriam-webster's
dictionary is called if there's like an
anti-dictionary uh but basically i think
you get the point if we move the knight
away
then the queen behind the knight is
attacking the queen on d8
black has to attend to the check and the
logic
is that in the time that he spends
attending to the check we will take his
queen
and we are going to be up a queen there
is one flaw in that thinking if we
actually play knight f6 check
he can take that knight with his queen
simultaneously escaping the discovery
okay so we got to be very careful about
that i see this mist all the time
but in any case he's gotten queen see it
he has escaped whatever tension existed
along that file
and once again we have to find a good
move here now
what kinds of things am i thinking about
well we're two pawns up we have a great
position
let's not forget that our ultimate aim
here is to attack black's king
let's not forget our second ultimate aim
to attack the king we have to get rid of
the bishop the bishop
is the gatekeeper here on the king's
side and if we can get rid of it
it opens up the possibility for all of
these various checks now we cannot go
bishop h6 anymore because our queen is
no longer on d2 but what we can do
is we can go bishop to d4 right
contesting the bishop
so even if the bishops don't end up
getting traded it's a great idea
to interpose uh this bishop on g7
because right now it's black's strongest
piece it's the only piece that's really
doing anything at all
and without that piece black is nothing
else developed his king is just going to
get massacred
with our knight and our queen and
potentially even a rook that can come
into the game
i could have done that by the way as
well when in doubt identify pieces that
aren't doing anything and bring them
into the game that's a great strategy
for when you're not sure what to do we
could have just brought this rook on h1
into the game now some of you may be
thinking wait a minute daniel didn't you
say earlier that you wanted to open that
h file so
could you have gone h4 here absolutely
it's a little bit slow a little bit
right it takes a bunch of moves to do
that
but i could have absolutely done that as
well
okay so he has seeds to our demand to
trade bishops
he's probably going to bring his knight
out to c6 would be my guest
and that would be the correct move i
mean he has to somehow develop his
pieces
it's not going to help him because he's
a little too far gone he's down two
pawns
his king is very weak so maybe he'll try
to prolong the game
and we need to keep all our all of our
options open uh one
issue that i see okay so let's we'll
talk about issues later right now he's
threatening check man we always need to
watch for that kind of stuff how do we
protect against checkmate
without losing the momentum that we have
built up
on the king side well there's a couple
of options all right
and i think the simplest option is to
just get rid of this rook altogether i
i just don't want to see it there i'm
just going to go rook to d2 i'm going to
get out of e2
either we go for a rook trade which is
certainly something
i'm happy to entertain or the rook has
to move back away
that gives us time uh to basically
fulfill the attack
now one very important thing if he takes
our rook some of you might spot
the fork on e7 forking his king and his
queen
if we do that immediately after he takes
on d2 that is a problem because he can
go king f7
and then if we take his queen remember
that we still haven't captured the rook
on d2 which can now take
our queen and at the end of the day he's
going to be up a rook
so this these kinds of intermediate
moves you want to look for them do you
want to be very careful on making them
uh because they can backfire he's gone
queen e6 okay so he's gone queen e6
which means that he has
supported the rook with his queen
there's many ways to win this game from
this position his position is wide open
as you can see
but i always start by looking for ways
to win material right if we can find a
way to win
a significant chunk of material then we
basically we don't even really have to
calculate then we can
we can take that material and the attack
continues so what kind of material
gaining tactics can we be looking for
here first of all forks i mentioned that
many times
in these positions with a knight as
centralized as we have
we are looking for forks now there's two
forks that
you might see one is knight f4 not good
because he can take our rook
and simultaneously attack the queen the
other fork that is better is the move
knight c7
forking his queen and his rook
he's welcome to take our rook we're just
going to take back and that's not going
to do anything to disrupt the fork
uh there's a couple of lines that
confound this and that some of you may
be
seeing right now and you might be a
little bit scared of them like rookie
one-shot you can give us a check with
this rook
but if you follow along we just take the
rook he he takes with his queen and then
we slide our rook back
attacking the queen and we are still
attacking the rook with our knight
and that is why i my relationship to the
queen is
a problematic one and i think people
really need to work on
their understanding of how the queen
works queens are incredibly powerful
pieces but at the same time want to be
careful about what tasks you assign to
the queen
because queens are also easy to attack
and when they are attacked because they
are the most powerful piece
they almost always have to move uh and
that can create
actually a liability so we'll talk about
that after the game
but in the meantime he's got knight c6
this move makes a lot of noise it's
actually very creative move
he's counter-attacking our queen but
we're just gonna take his queen
he's gonna take our queen and we're
gonna take his knight
and at the end of the day we are going
to be up another night and we're gonna
be up two pawns
from our previous marriage and i don't
know why i said that but
it sounded right so we're going to be up
a night in two pawns
and uh the rest is going to be very easy
now i know that some of you probably
are are wondering you know how do i
convert
advantages in the end game let's say i'm
up on night i always
miss wins in the end game and and that
is a source
of problems for a lot of players they
they get into end games
where they're up a lot of pieces or just
one piece uh and they don't know how to
actually convert that advantage so
hopefully our opponent doesn't resign so
i can talk about it a little now first
of all
we need to protect this knight so let's
go c3 to establish it on d4
and fundamentally uh well there's two
main ways
of winning an endgame like this when
we're up this much material
the simplest one is to create a past
pawn a pass pawn is a pawn
that is on a file where it is
uncontested by any opposing pawns if it
simply goes forward it will promote
obviously pieces might stop it but a
passport refers only to the absence of
obstructing pawns not to abstract pieces
that's method number one and in order to
create a password we have to identify
where on the board we can create it what
i'm seeing here is that we have a pawn
majority here we have three pawns
against
our opponents too and so what we can do
is we can
just try to create a pass bond here and
that's going to tie this over pretty
well
uh that pass pawn is going to be on the
file we're going to use our extra piece
we're going to use all of our pieces
which is very important in the end game
to keep all of your pieces active
we're going to use it to supervise that
pawn and to guide it
all the way to promotion very simple and
our opponent resigns
the position is completely losing and
the win is going to be very elementary
and that was a very interesting game
ladies and gentlemen now let's quickly
go over it
uh summarize and make a couple of
important moments points before we wrap
up
now our opponent played the modern as i
explained
this is an opening and literally it's in
the name modern
right it's an opening that was laughed
at
150 years ago because why would you
allow your opponent control of the
center but that's kind of the point
black establishes this sort of maginot
line
like established establishes this i
don't even know how to
call it right he's going the bishop he's
really looking at white center from a
distance
uh and he's going to start attacking it
with all of these
pieces and pawns and he's going to
slowly bring his pieces into the center
so it's a tremendously risky way of
playing but if
people play this well the modern can
also be one of the most dangerous
weapons that white has to reckon with
because it creates a very unbalanced
position so what did i do i developed my
bishop to e3
i played the move a4 to stop him from
advancing the pawn
to b5 and claiming space on the queen
side
now a very important move f3 uh
defending the pawn on e4
and also stopping his knight from coming
to g4 we go queen d2 as i explained
we are preparing the move bishop h6 so
if he played some random move
we would have forced the bishop trade
and this is a big blow for black
by the way if you want to know how to
avoid this bishop trade pro tip
you can play this move this looks dumb
like why are we putting the rook here
the point is that if we go bishop h6 the
bishop can now slide back to ha
and remember there used to be a rook on
f8 now there is but an empty square
so that is a very classical way of
actually preserving the bishop but our
opponent found another way to do that he
played e5
striking in the center so we defend the
center now he strikes in the center
again and really the pivotal point was
here
the move f4 would be tempting but he
attacks the knight
and then he forks our knight and our
bishop compare
this situation to the situation that
occurred here
here and i'm going to flip back to the
other situation he had a knight on d7
here
there's no such thing here he has a
queen on d8 and that queen is all alone
and i think this is the detail that won
me the game because the move d4
while it seems to fork the knight on the
bishop actually does it i have the time
to take on c5 isolating the spawn on d4
and then i'm gonna take it on the next
move
so without that our opponent tried to
push c4 but we got our knight around to
e4 exploiting once again the pin against
the queen
here we could have easily grabbed the
pawn on d5 but instead we said okay
this bishop on e6 is like the glue guy
it's like the sixth man
if we eliminate that piece his entire
position collapses and that is exactly
what happened
he tried the move knight d3 very
creative play by our opponent
intercepting
our defense of the knight but as it
turned out by the way if he would have
taken the knight instead
we would have simply gone bishop e4
queen takes queen his force
and now we end up in a situation where
he literally pays the ultimate price for
not developing his queen side his rook
is trapped
i suppose he can go knight c6 but now
his other rook is lost
due to a skewer against his rook so it's
not a surprise that all of this stuff
happens
because he's got so many holes in his
position and that's just what happens
you got to look for tactics when you
sense that your opponent
your opponent's position is on the verge
of collapse and
ultimately we want a second pawn finally
we do succeed in trading our bishop
and we get the rook out of there and now
we find the fork
to win a bunch of material and win the
game so just very quickly if he goes
rookie one check
queen takes when we go rook d1 attacking
the queen attacking the rook
if he tries some shenanigans with queen
to a2 trying to checkmate us on a1 well
we can take the rook
and conveniently open up an escape
square for the king if he takes on h1 we
can either take the rook
or we can go straight for the checkmate
with rook e8 anything is good
so after that our opponent decided to go
knight c6
now we liquidate into an end game where
we are up a knight and two pawns and
here finally
we signal that we know what the main
plan is which is to create a past pawn
and in a separate video i will certainly
be talking about what
the uh proper technique is in such
positions
but i'm basically showing the the
essentials of it which is to create that
passport and then use the king knight
and rook
to supervise it all the way to promotion
or force our opponent to trade rooks
which would
of course be in our favor we can create
another passport potentially on the
other side of the board
as long as we can keep the night
protected and so our opponent decided to
resign
a very very good game here by by my
opponent i appreciate
the chance to play him i think this was
a very instructive game
what are the key takeaways number one do
not dismiss openings like the modern
they are legit and they're just a
different way of looking at the game but
if you're a beginner
i would not recommend starting with this
i would recommend first learning how to
play
by occupying the center and then only
when you've mastered that sort of
branching out to these
openings like modern or the perk or
actually the scan is
not one of those openings but the perk
is one d6 same kind of idea it's
actually the
sister opening to the modern it often
transposes
okay so my bad didn't mean to do that
okay so here we develop our pieces with
the knights or the center
other other takeaways from the game
obviously
the concept of not rushing right we at
many points there was a move that was
very tempting
but we didn't make it uh because we
thought a little bit deeper and the same
goes for observations
uh there were many moments when it
seemed like the situation was in our
opponent's favor he was winning a piece
but we constantly question our
assumptions and this this philosophy of
questioning the assumptions you make
also by the way uh
in regards to castling long even though
we had pushed a pawn out to a4
not a big deal as it turned out uh you
want to continually do that
and that helps you grow as a chess
player it helps you grow as a thinker
and it helps you develop more robust
ways of looking at chess
so with all that being said that was a
lot that was a very interesting game
and i think that's more than enough for
one video so i'll wrap up here
this was certainly a very very combative
gaming it's a good opponent
so i will try my best to answer the
questions uh in the comments and i'm
sure that people will have a lot
so i hope you folks enjoyed this uh
next installment in grand master plays
beginner slash intermediate player
and i will certainly be making more as i
go along and be on the lookout for more
speedrun videos of course uh coming out
on the daily
thank you very much and i'll see you
soon in the next video bye
[Music]
you